N
ORIGINALS."
YOUR HOST, TUCKER CARLSON.
>> Tucker: WELCOME TO SEASON
TWO OF "TUCKER CARLSON
ORIGINALS."
A YEAR AND A HALF AGO A GROUP OF
PRODUCERS AND I SAT DOWN AT
DINNER AND TALKED ABOUT HOW TO
GO A LITTLE DEEPER INTO SOME OF
THE TOPICS WE COVER.
WOULDN'T IT BE INTERESTING TO
SPEND MORE THAN THREE AND HALF
MINUTES ON A SUBJECT THAT
MATTERS TO OUR VIEWERS?
WHAT AN IT BE COOL TO MAKE A
DOCUMENTARY?
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS, CABLE NEWS
COMPANIES DON'T MAKE
DOCUMENTARIES.
THEY MAKE CABLE NEWS.
AND THEY DO A PRETTY GOOD JOB.
BUT WE WENT TO FOX NEWS AND
ASKED, COULD WE DO THIS?
TO OUR AMAZEMENT AND DELIGHT
THEY SAID YES, YOU CAN.
SO FOR THE LAST YEAR, WE HAVE
MADE A SERIES OF LONG FORM
DOCUMENTARIES ABOUT ISSUES THAT
WE THINK MATTER TO THE COUNTRY
AND TO YOU.
AND THEY HAVE WORKED BETTER THAN
WE EVER EXPECTED.
WE ARE PROUD OF WHAT WE HAVE
CREATED.
WE ARE DOING ANOTHER SEASON, AND
FOR A PREVIEW OF THAT WE ARE
JOINED BY THE DIABOLICAL GENUS,
THE MAN BEHIND ALL OF THIS, THE
VICE PRESIDENT HERE AT FOX NEWS.
GOOD TO SEE YOU ON CAMERA FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN A LONG TIME.
THIS HAS BECOME SOMETHING NOT --
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY WE DID
NOT EXPECTED TO BECOME AT ALL.
WE KNEW HE WANTED TO DO IT AND
WE KNEW FOX WAS SUPPORTING US.
WE WENT TO AT LEAST 30 STATES.
WE WENT TO SEVERAL COUNTRIES.
AND WE GOT A LOT OF SUPPORT FROM
THE AUDIENCE BECAUSE THEY WERE
NOT ABLE TO CONSUME THIS
ANYWHERE ELSE.
WE RATTLED A FEW PEOPLE IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA OR WHAT NOT.
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
PERHAPS SOME OF THE STORIES ARE
CONTROVERSIAL.
BUT THEY ARE TOPICS THAT PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT DEEPLY.
THEY ACTUALLY NEED TO SPEND TIME
DISSECTING THEM AND
UNDERSTANDING THEM AND THAT IS
WHAT WE DO IN THESE
DOCUMENTARIES.
THEY ARE SHOT BEAUTIFULLY.
WE'VE GOT THE BEST TEAM.
BUT THE TEAM THAT DOES THE
NIGHTLY SHOW KNOWS WHAT STORIES
MATTER TO PEOPLE.
THEY ARE PART OF THIS, AND THAT
IS WHY I THINK THAT WORKS.
>> YOU HATE TO SUCK UP TO YOUR
EMPLOYER.
I SEE PEOPLE ALL THE TIME
SUCKING UP TO THEIR EMPLOYERS.
THEY WORK FOR THESE HORRIBLE
COMPANIES AND FORCE THEM TO READ
THE PROPAGANDA.
BUT I'D HAVE TO SAY, FOX NEWS
HAS GONE ALL IN AND SUPPORT OF
THIS.
SOME OF THE STUFF THAT WE'VE
PRODUCED HAS NOT BEEN POPULAR
WITH NBC, CNN.
AND YOU WOULD KNOW SINCE YOU DO
WITH IT, BUT FOXES STOOD BEHIND
US COMPLETELY.
>> 100%.
THERE HASN'T BEEN A SINGLE TIME
WHERE THEY'VE TOLD US, DON'T
TALK ABOUT THIS, DON'T TALK
ABOUT THAT, GOING TO COVER THAT
STORY, DON'T COVER THAT STORY.
WE'VE DECIDED TO GO TO HUNGRY
AND WE ARE GOING TO INVESTIGATE
HOW THEY TOOK A DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO GEORGE SOROS AND
DIVE INTO THAT AND SEE HOW MAYBE
WE CAN LEARN SOMETHING HERE IN
AMERICA.
WE DID THAT ON THEIR OWN AND
THEY HAVE GIVEN US THE
RESOURCES --
>> Tucker: THEY HAVE!
>> "THE NEW YORK TIMES" DIDN'T
LOVE WITH THAT WE WERE THERE FOR
A WEEK INVESTIGATING HOW THEY
TAKE A DIFFERENT APPROACH TO
THEIR COUNTRY.
WE SOMEHOW ENDED UP IN SERBIA.
BUT YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT IS
WHAT MAKES THE SERIES DIFFERENT.
THAT IS WHY IT IS RESONATED WITH
PEOPLE.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE ABLE TO GO
OUT FOR SEASON TO UNCOVER EVEN
MORE TOPICS THAT ARE EQUALLY
GOING TO BE AS INSIGHTFUL AS
WHAT WE DID IN THE FIRST SEASON,
BUT NOBODY IS TALKED ABOUT SOME
OF THESE.
>> Tucker: IT PUSH THE
BOUNDARIES.
IT'S A LITTLE WEIRD TO WAKE UP
AT 52 AND REALIZE YOU WORK FOR
THE LAST STRONGHOLD OF
FREE SPEECH AND ALL OF MASS
MEDIA.
I DID NOT EXPECT THAT.
THE LAST PLACE WHERE YOU CAN SAY
WHAT YOU THINK IS TRUE AND YOUR
BOSSES WILL BACK YOU UP.
WHY IS THE SEASON BETTER?
SPEAK OF THE SEASON IS BETTER --
FIRST OF ALL, IT IS ON
FOX NATION.
WE WERE DOING THIS ON YOUTUBE OR
SOME OTHER OUTLET, THEY WOULD BE
BANNING IT.
WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO IT.
YOU CAN GO THERE, YOU CAN SIGN
UP.
YOU GET EVERYTHING FROM
TESTOSTERONE LEVELS.
LAST SEASON WE COVERED UFOs
AND THAT PHENOMENON.
WE DIVED INTO CATTLE RELATIONS A
LITTLE BIT.
BUT THESE SEASONS WE ARE LOOKING
INTO THAT FINE TUNE APPROACH.
>> Tucker: IT'S THE PERFECT
STORY BECAUSE IT IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS -- YOU HEAR ABOUT IT AND
DO THINK, THAT IS TOO CRAZY TO
BE REAL.
YOU ASKED QUESTIONS, SHUT UP
CONSPIRACY MONGER!
AND THEN YOU GO IN DEEPER AND
YOU ASK, WHAT IS THIS?
AND I THINK WE DID THAT.
>> BE DEAD.
THIS GUY IS GOING TO BE
DEMONSTRATING -- IT CAN'T BE
HUMANS JUST JUST GOING THERE --D
MUTILATE THEM AT THE SCALE